بنتين وصبي بنتين وصبي البنت عمرها 17 سنه
وبنت عمرها اربع سنين والصبي عمره 12 سنه
طيب كان هذا جزءا من مقابله ام احمد مع
قناه العربيه في مخيم من مخيمات مدينه
الاصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب بعد ايام من
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا
اللاجئه السوريه فقدت اطفالها الثلاثه
نتيجه الزلزال وتعرض زوجها لحادث اليم في
سوريا بعد انتهاء مراسم دفن اطفاله هناك
ولا يعلم احد عنه اي شيء حتى اللحظه الى
اسطنبول جاءت ام احمد للحصول على بطاقه
حمايه مؤقته لها ولطفلها الناجي من تحت
الانقاض لكن طيف اطفالها الثلاثه لا
يفارقها في اول شهر رمضان تمضيه بدونهم
رمضان الماضي كتير كان حلو
اي والله كان اولادي معي بطلع جيب لهم
يعني حلوه عيد اشتري لون ثياب كتير كنا
مبسوطين الحمد لله بس هذا هذا الرمضان
كتير ماساوي علي مع بصدق ما بصدق شيء اللي
صار معي ما بصدق هلا بحسوا كانه حلم لم
تنجح في الحصول على بطاقه حمايه مؤقته
لذلك قررت العوده مجددا الى ولايه غاز
عنتاب لكن الى اين ستعود فمنزلها تهدم ولا
مكان يؤويها ما مشي حاله هويتي هون وبدي
ارجع هلا على الاصلاحيه
غازي عنتاب بس ما عم بعرف وين بدي ابرك
يعني بيتي انا انهدم نعم
بعرف الحياه اغلقت ابوابها في وجه ام احمد
العالقه في ذكريات الماضي والرافضه
للانتقال الى قادم ايام لا يجمعها مع
اطفالها الذين رحلوا وزوجها الذي لا تعلم
عنه شيء زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه
سيدنا الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات